i still very much consider myself to be
a beginner in all things youtube but i
have now been posting on this platform
for a little bit over a year and i've
learned some lessons that i want to
share with you this is not a video on
how to make a youtube video
but rather just the lessons that i've
learned that have helped me to start
this channel and grow without the use of
other social media websites that will
hopefully be helpful for you as you
start your own creative goals be that
youtube music writing or all of the
above also because i am pretty nerdy
i've included some recommendations of
books that have been helpful for me as
resources that will hopefully be helpful
for you and because i value your time
all the information will be time stamped
below and if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up to help support my
channel and if not by all means thumbs
it down but give me some feedback in the
comments so that i know what to work on
okay so let's start from the beginning
why did i start a youtube channel
believe it or not i actually never
really intended to start a youtube
channel it actually began because i had
gotten so pumped about motivating people
to achieve their goals because my
husband and i had just built our own
home as our own general contractors and
when i say that we built it i mean that
for a year we were there every evening
after work and every weekend that we had
free so that we could lay flooring put
up windows put up siding all the above
we did have some subcontractor help for
certain things but it was a monster of a
project for somebody who had never done
something like that before specifically
for me my husband has a lot of
construction experience but i didn't
know anything about permits or codes or
construction really and i had to learn
things that i had never done before like
how to drive an excavator during this
time i had a co-worker who is awesome at
makeup and she was telling me about how
she was starting her own makeup line i
could see the glow on her face when she
would talk about this makeup line it was
like her little baby like this project
that she had a dream for but she was a
little bit nervous about and i remember
telling her you have got to start a
youtube channel you are so awesome at
makeup you can do this
and she would tell me things like no
youtube is too saturated it's not going
to work and all these reasons
i called them excuses
and i remember as i was telling her
about this
i heard a voice in my head saying
yesi you're being a hypocrite right now
you're wanting to encourage her and
motivate her to put herself out there
risking that people will judge her or
dislike her or that just plain won't
work out she will have wasted her time
and energy on this
but what about you if you're gonna talk
the talk then you have to walk the walk
i kept trying to encourage her because i
saw the potential in her but i realized
that i had to see the potential in me
that before i could approach her about
facing her fear i had to face my own
fear
face my fear why do i say that you see
me talking in front of this camera and
it may seem natural and i can be a very
goofy and friendly person but i'm very
much introverted at heart and i actually
struggled with social anxiety for years
and really before starting this youtube
channel i hadn't had social media and
actually six years now so for me to go
from this quiet shy
generally pretty private person to all
of a sudden posting myself out there on
the internet was pretty huge
and the more i try to encourage my
friend the more i realized this
encouragement was really for me
that really if i believed she could do
it i had to believe in myself and i had
to take my own advice and face my own
fear and do the thing that made me
uncomfortable
putting myself out there online guys i'm
getting nervous just thinking about it i
did it i posted my first video clever
ways to repurpose containers or
something like that and the thumbnail
was horrible that should be an
indication of how great that video is
but it was like my voice was shaky you
could tell that i was nervous i didn't
even have any b-roll because i didn't
know what the heck that was or how to do
it so it's just me talking in this very
monotone voice
i cringe just thinking about it however
i'm also really incredibly proud because
i did it i did the thing that i was
afraid to do and this is the first
lesson that i want to share with you
cast the stone
do it cast the stone i love mother
teresa's famous quote i alone cannot
change the world but i can cast a stone
across the waters to create many ripples
so ask yourself what is that thing that
you've been wanting to do could it be
that voice that's telling you to
audition for that play to start singing
lessons or start your own youtube
channel
ignore the excuses in your head and just
take the first step and don't think of
this project as a whole when my husband
and i started thinking about how we
would finish the house or thinking about
the completion we immediately began to
feel overwhelmed but when we broke it
down into tiny pieces like for example
this week we will lay flooring it
suddenly became obtainable and then we
started to feel a sense of satisfaction
as we actually achieve those small goals
so that would be my first lesson to you
is don't focus on the big picture ask
yourself what's one thing that you can
do right now to get started
and do it
the first step is the hardest it's where
you meet the most resistance so
congratulate yourself and the fact that
you actually did it
even if the end result makes you cringe
like me in that first video but hey at
least you did it it's better than not
having tried at all if you feel a lot of
pushback or resistance to starting your
goals two books that have been very
helpful to me have been atomic habits by
james clear and the compound effect by
darren hardy the compound effect talks a
lot about how making tiny changes to
your habits can accumulate and create
profound changes over time it was highly
motivating to me
atomic habits by james clear actually
lays a clear picture of step by step
what actions you need to take to get to
where you want to be so check these out
and let me know what you think these
have been of tremendous value to me
vulnerability makes us human not weak
the most difficult video for me to film
was actually not my first one it was how
i overcame social anxiety and this one
was again not one that i really wanted
to film but one that i just felt like i
had to and i remember this day
specifically i met with my husband and i
told him i feel like i have to talk
about something that i don't want to i
don't want to post this because i don't
want to reveal a side of me that i've
been hiding for years i remember telling
him that people already judge you before
they even meet you i don't want to
reveal my weaknesses for people to judge
or even ridicule but i felt in my heart
i have to because most of what you see
on social media is people posting their
perfect pictures living their perfect
lives and i knew that i wanted something
different for this channel but i wanted
to talk about real life and real
problems that precisely because i'm not
perfect and because i don't have it all
together i could reach the people that
are sick and tired of superficiality but
i knew that to achieve that i had to
first put aside my pride and my vanity
and open up about my struggles and my
weaknesses i have recently been reading
the book breaking the habit of being
yourself by joe dispenza an awesome book
i highly recommend it it's very much a
sciency book where he talks about
quantum physics and energy and he ties
it all into how it's related to the
power of our mind it's perfect for nerds
like me but he mentions that energy is
not created or destroyed you can choose
to use your energy on dwelling on the
past worrying about the future worrying
about people accepting you or whether or
not things will work out or you can
choose to let all of that go and focus
that energy on actually accomplishing
your goals and your dreams the moment i
posted that video was like a wall had
just come down because i no longer had
to spend energy trying to hide an aspect
of myself and who i was and it gave me a
sense of freedom
know your why
one of the books that has really
resonated with me is start with why by
simon sinek and a narrative that has
really stuck with me is a little
something like this if i were to pay you
money to walk from the top of one
building to another across a rope you
would likely look at me and say heck no
i'm not risking my life for that but if
i told you that on the other building is
your child and this building is about to
fall down or burn down then you may be
more likely to actually do it and go
across to try to save your child
but why
the action is the same you're still
walking from the top of one building to
another across a rope it's because your
why changed the moment we put a child on
that other side of the building and that
building's gonna burn down or it's gonna
fall down then the story changes your
motivation and your reason why changes
having a baby who still wakes me up
almost every single night a toddler and
a full-time job i have to get up at five
in the morning to be able to research
video topics script edit film etc and
having my why
becomes very important to be able to get
out of the bed in the morning because if
it was about what i wanted
i would say i'm going back to bed now i
will say that balance is something that
i find very important so i am not
telling you to overwork yourself because
you have to make your health a priority
but rather to try to ask yourself the
question what motivates me are you
motivated by fame are you motivated by
financial independence by the ability to
spend more time with your family or your
friends or to have better health
truly take a quiet moment and ask
yourself and if you can even better
write it down my husband and i worked
overtime every single week for months to
try to get out of debt when we learned
about dave ramsey and the fire movement
and during this physically and
emotionally exhausting time
our reason why was what got us out of
bed and out that door every morning so
find your why
perfectionism is overrated
i think that we live in a culture that
rewards perfectionism and music is a
good thing i mean what are we told in
job interviews when they ask you what
your biggest weakness is and you're
supposed to say
i'm a perfectionist
but really and truly perfectionism can
be self-sabotage
when i posted my first video i cringed
the entire time i was editing you could
tell that i was nervous the lighting was
off my editing was non-existent in my
voice
but honestly one year later that voice
has still not gone away i still hear it
telling me things like your voice is too
monotone people are gonna hate that your
lighting is off your sound is too loud
it's distracting your stat is too quiet
it's too boring through developing
self-awareness i've learned that
perfectionism has actually stopped me
from doing many things but some of the
best moments in my life has been a
result of doing things
crappily but happily
just to give you a backstory i am not a
singer but one of my very best memories
in high school was when i signed up for
a talent show and i sang my heart out to
the quiero in front of 300 people and i
loved every second of it and even though
people actually booed me
they didn't have the guts to do what i
did
so even though i lost
i still won
i think that we sometimes have to quit
putting value in obtaining first place
or being the best at something and focus
on actually making improvement but also
actually congratulating ourselves for
that improvement even if it's something
tiny or minor
i want to challenge you to train your
brain to see the positive to be aware of
your flaws and the need for improvement
but also to see when you actually are
improving and congratulate yourself for
it this will help keep and boost your
motivation as you actually see
improvements even if they're so small
instead of seeing how far you have left
to go to accomplish what you want to do
one of the things that i try to do to
kind of keep and boost motivation is
every night before going to bed thinking
of all of the wins for that day even if
it was a horrible day and all i can
think about is
well i cooked a healthy meal or i took
out the trash
and if it helps you to actually write
these down because then when you've had
a horrible day and you just can't think
of anything you can actually look back
at that journal and see yeah i am making
improvements the more you do it the more
it becomes automatic and then over time
you start to build that momentum that
simon talks about and sometimes when you
do this you will find that you did a lot
more than you gave yourself credit for
stay true to your values
when i first started this youtube
channel i was told that it was never
going to go anywhere never going to grow
because i don't use other social media
websites like facebook or instagram i
talk about why i don't have these sorts
of websites in my video why i quit
social media and when you look up how to
start a youtube channel most of the
people on the internet are gonna tell
you that you should have these sorts of
websites in order to promote your
content now please don't get me wrong
i'm not telling you that you shouldn't
have social media to promote whatever
content you have but for me it was
important that i'd not do that and so i
thought about it for a brief second
because it felt like well darn there's
no other way and i came to the
conclusion that i had three different
choices
one i could accept their remarks and not
even try
two i could do what the youtube guru
said i had to do but not be true to
myself or three i could stay true to my
values and accept that it may not work
out i chose option 3 because even though
i didn't know what kind of content i
wanted my youtube channel to have i knew
one thing and i had that very clear in
my heart and that is that i did not want
to be the instagram star that had the
perfect life that i was perfect i wanted
to talk about my vulnerabilities and my
screw-ups i wanted to then kind of turn
all those things into something positive
that could be encouraging and motivating
and just relatable so for me not to use
other social media platforms to promote
youtube was important but for you maybe
other people have told you that you'll
never make it in the music industry
because you don't have a pretty face or
that you're never going to be an actor
because you don't have the right body
type or maybe you've been told that your
hobby isn't for boys or vice versa
whatever lie you've been told i want to
challenge you to consider that it may
have nothing to do with you but
everything to do with them it is often
the case that the people that make those
sorts of destructive comments haven't
done the work to get to where they want
to be in life
you're building this tall tower and
they're afraid that your building is
going to be bigger and shinier than
theirs so they have to destroy yours
instead of working on their own fighting
the battle with them to prove yourself
to them is a waste of your time and
energy instead focus that precious
energy on building that tower of yours
and don't let those negative comments
tear you down i've actually had some
hateful comments that youtube has
actually took down because of profanity
and something that has helped me
assimilate this is to ask myself
what does it say about them
a lot of people will criticize and
attack you and some people are just
plain rude especially when it comes to
the internet but at the end of the day i
know that it says a lot more about them
than it does about me so criticism will
come just know that 100 guarantee but
know whether or not it's constructive or
destructive in nature and kind of just
try to take yourself out of the picture
for a moment and consider whether or not
it actually has anything to do with you
i talk more in depth about this in my
video five steps for dealing with
critics and haters check it out if
you're interested i hope that these tips
have been helpful for you and let me
know what creative projects are you
working on i'd love to hear from you and
i wish you all the best in your
endeavors until next time bye
and i narrowed a narrow road of
a narrative by james clear and you're
you're really distracting me
[Music]